today on the matt well show michelle
obama is once again complaining about
the persecution she's suffered as a
black woman in america she's not alone
lebron james oprah winfrey meghan markle
other black millionaires and
billionaires have all frequently
complained about our racist
system of white privilege today we're
going to talk about the victims
uh here and and reflect on their stories
also five headlines including
dr fauci finally giving a definitive
date sort of for when we can return to
normal
uh it's a year away and the cia doubles
down releasing yet another woke ad plus
sarah
silverman uh comes comes after caitlyn
jenner proving a few points that i'll
explain today
and in our daily cancellation we'll
consider the story of
the rapper who was shot and killed by a
15 year old boy for his rolex watch
what should we say about a man who
promotes street violence and then dies
by it
well we could say a lot and i will today
and it'll make people very mad probably
all of that
and more today on the matt well show
[Music]
you know it could be really hard
sometimes to find a good
really good chair especially a good
office chair and you know the difference
between a
you know one that's uh it's no good
because you get up the end of the day
your back is all there's all kinds of
messed up and there's a difference
between that
and a really good office chair that
gives you the kind of support you need
and i have that right now in my life i'm
happy to say
sitting in it right now the x chair x
chair has your office chair
needs covered the secret is not only
their patented dynamic variable lumbar
support which offers unbelievable
lumbar support to your lower back not
exactly sure what the lumbar is but i
know that it's supported for sure by
this chair
but now thanks to the new xhmt
technology
you can also get heat and massage
therapy while you're sitting at your
desk so if you're old and decrepit like
me
and you need that that extra help you
can get it instead of your old
uncomfortable office chair
now you can look forward to spending
hours sitting in the ultimate
therapeutic massager
uh if you're going to be sitting down
all day why not make sure you take care
of your comfort and your health as well
x chair is on sale right now for a
hundred dollars off go to
xchairwalsh.com
that's the letter x chair walsh.com or
call one eight four four four x chair
x chair has a thirty day guarantee of
complete comfort and you can finance
your purchase for as little as thirty
dollars a month
go to xchairwalsh.com now and use code x
wheels for free
x-wheel bladecasters xchairwalsh.com
it's good to you know keep things in
perspective you may believe that your
life is difficult but you should realize
that there are people out there who face
struggles and obstacles hardships and
persecution
far beyond what you have ever known or
will ever experience
uh you've been through your own trials
perhaps but at least your life
hasn't been as hard on you as it has
been on michelle obama
the former first lady who graduated from
two ivy league schools became first lady
by the age of 45
is now worth a combined 135 million
dollars along with her husband
has always been eager to talk about the
many ways in which this country has
oppressed her
she returned to that theme in a recent
interview with cbs telling the outlet
that
she quote lived in fear or lives in fear
and is afraid of getting randomly gunned
down by the cops while
shopping for groceries or walking her
dog apparently the fact that she gets
secret service protection everywhere she
goes is not enough to make her feel
secure
she considers it plausible that a racist
cop might run up and
execute a former first lady on the spot
for no reason
obama is also concerned that her
daughters will get racially profiled
while driving
she lies awake at night tossing and
turning fearing that some police
officers
police officer with a professional death
wish will harass the famous daughters of
a united states president
these are all very real fears that she
has and don't ever doubt these fears
don't doubt them here she is describing
them many of us still
live in fear as we go to the grocery
store or
worry about our dogs walking our dogs or
allowing our children to get a license i
mean just imagine
aren't your girls driving they're
driving but every time they get in a car
by themselves
i worry about what assumption is being
made by somebody who doesn't know
everything about them the fact that they
are good students
and polite girls but maybe they're
playing their music a little loud maybe
somebody sees the back of their head
and makes an assumption i like so many
parents black kids have to that the the
innocent act of getting a license puts
fear in our hearts um so
i think i think we have to talk about it
more and we have to ask our
fellow citizens to listen a bit more and
to believe
us yeah just to be clear again
when she talks about being afraid of
walking down the street or you know
walking her dog or
going to the grocery store that is what
she's saying she's saying she's afraid
that a cop will shoot her
that's the claim being made by michelle
obama michelle obama is afraid that a
cop
will shoot her she says
and why won't someone listen to her she
asks you know they just need to listen
to us
yes why won't someone listen to michelle
obama michelle obama is tired of being
ignored
she wrote a book that sold 10 million
copies in five months
clearly nobody cares what she has to say
nobody is listening to her
it's just as clear that only black
parents have to worry about their kids
behind the wheel
white parents have no such concern you
know when i was 17 and i got my license
and i went out on the roads
my parents were they were sleeping easy
it was no problem
weren't worried at all we white parents
simply cannot conceive
of living a life as difficult as that of
a beloved
multi-millionaire celebrity who charges
two hundred thousand dollars to give a
45-minute speech
can't even we can't wrap our heads
around it
if you're not yet convinced that
michelle obama is a victim and that her
bitterness towards this country is
warranted i need only remind you of a
segment from her podcast a few months
ago
where she talked about the racism she
experienced even while in the white
house
what you're about to hear is very
difficult to listen to it'll send
chills down your spine but it is your
responsibility
to confront this because this is what is
happening to michelle obama
you're not going to be able to you're
not going to believe this listen
[Music]
so i'm standing there with two little
black girls
another black female adult they're in
soccer uniforms
and a white woman cuts right in front of
us
to order like she didn't even see us
and i literally and the the girl behind
the counter
almost took her order and i said excuse
me
as if you don't see us four people
standing right here you just jumped in
line
she didn't apologize she never looked me
in my eye she didn't know it was me
all she saw was a black person or a
group of black people or maybe she
didn't even see that
what white folks don't understand it's
like that
that is so telling of how white america
views
people who are not like them you know we
don't exist
[Music]
she doesn't exist someone noticed
michelle obama she's not being noticed
you heard that right michelle obama
years later specifically remembers
one time when someone cut in front of
her in line and is still complaining
about it
who can blame her i mean obviously this
was racism there could be
no other explanation someone cut in
front of her in line
and she you know by the way remember
before she was talking about don't make
assumptions about people
she jumped to the she assumed that this
person is racist
that's the assumption she made but but
it's it's it's uh
she she can make that assumption because
it's not as though
all humans on the face of this planet
have had similar experiences
it's not as though line cutters are
globally reviled
precisely because we've all encountered
this many times
no this is michelle obama's cross to
carry just think about this
michelle obama was delayed in getting
ice cream for upwards of 15
seconds 15 seconds imagine
she could have starved her children
could have starved
all because they're black now lest you
think that michelle obama is the only
fabulously wealthy famous and beloved
black celebrity
to be persecuted by this country i must
also remind you of lebron
james lebron net worth 500 million
dollars who's
been a millionaire athlete since the age
of 18 and was nationally acclaimed even
before that it would be accurate to say
that lebron
has been a celebrated and nationally
recognized athlete for the vast majority
of his life
almost his entire life going back into
childhood
but even so lebron has suffered the sort
of maltreatment
that the average white man cannot
comprehend the nba the nba star has
like michelle often claimed to be too
afraid to walk down the street
despite being surrounded by armed
security living in a multi-million
dollar mansion in a posh
los angeles suburb lebron is worried
that some crazed racist cop will run up
and shoot him dead
such a thing has literally never
happened nothing like that has ever
happened
but he's worried that it will and his
fear should be validated
in fairness lebron has experienced hate
crimes in the past
um who can forget the time when lebron
claimed that someone
spray-painted the n-word somewhere on
his property now in fact i say who can
forget
everyone has forgotten but um he did
actually claim this
and he spoke out against the hate crime
courageously was applauded by the media
now the funny thing is that the cops
showed up to investigate and they never
found any racist graffiti
it had been uh painted over already
nothing strange about that calling the
cops to investigate
graffiti but painting over it before
they arrive
who could question that the media
certainly didn't question it
and what about oprah winfrey net worth
2.7 billion dollars
she especially in recent years has taken
to denouncing white privilege as well
now sure she has more wealth and power
than the average white person could
could hope to accrue in 10 000 lifetimes
but the average white
white person still has something that
oprah winfrey doesn't
whiteness what is whiteness worth
what can you cash it in for well that
isn't explained exactly but the point is
that
if you're a white man living in a 900
square foot modular home
and feeding your children canned tuna
for dinner tonight you are more
privileged than oprah winfrey
as she explains here there are white
people who are not as powerful
as the system of white people the task
system that's
been put in place but they still
no matter where they are on the wrong
or the ladder of success they still have
their whiteness
they still have their whiteness
something you say to the guy
feeding the kids tuna in the modular
home you have your whiteness
you got that at least can't afford
medical bills but you have your
whiteness
cash that in cash that in at the cosmic
prize counter
maybe it'll be good for a couple jolly
ranchers and a chinese finger trap
imagine being oprah i mean it must be so
hard
that's why oprah was the perfect person
to speak to and commiserate with
meghan markle who's sort of black but
fully persecuted
a hollywood actress turned royalty
turned media mogul
um and it's unclear why she was
deserving of any of those titles at all
being that she has no talent to speak of
whatsoever but
surely she has known troubles and
tribulations that a white mother
waitressing at a denny's
never has or never will likewise for
sean p
diddy combs who penned an open letter to
corporate america a few weeks ago
blasting the corporate world for
discriminating against people like
himself
now sean combs is worth 900 million
dollars
despite the fact that he's never
produced anything of value in his entire
life
uh he's been a millionaire since his
early 20s
that's also when he killed tupac
allegedly but none of that can erase the
pain
caused by the unspecified corporate
villains who have caused him
unspecified harm who knows maybe he
could be worth one billion already if
not for that discrimination
can you imagine that can you imagine
not being a billionaire that's the sort
of reality that sean combs has to face
every day
at least for a few more years until he
actually is a billionaire all of this
raises the question
when will america finally become the
sort of country where black people can
succeed
or at least i mean succeed more succeed
more than being millionaires and
billionaires and some of the most famous
and powerful people
in the country that's the question
in closing i want to give you a
statistic that will shock you to your
core
and you're not going to believe this but
it's true
did you know that there are today
no black trillionaires
none not one
not even oprah still think white
privilege is a myth
well clearly you're wrong
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know there's so many things out
there especially on the internet um
looking to indoctrinate your kids a lot
a lot of content out there supposedly
made for kids but uh
not exactly expressing um
the kind of values that you want for
your kids and that's why when you find
something
that teaches your kids the kind of
information they need to know uh
that's really important and that's why i
want to tell you about the tuttle twin
show
how do you describe economics to a
seven-year-old uh should should your
pre-teen
care about the government well schools
today aren't teaching the principles of
freedom history is watered down key
principles
omitted altogether and time and
attention are given to things of lesser
importance shall we say
woke socialist ideas are creeping into
our classrooms doing a lot more than
creeping into them in a lot of cases so
our friends at tuttle twins are doing
something about it they're creating the
tuttle twin show
an animated show that teaches kids
principles of freedom like free market
economics limited government and free
speech
title twins just opened an investment
round to the public at
www.tuttletwins.tv
where anyone can invest in the show and
help bring it to life so that's pretty
exciting people are living at the total
win show
is now the world's number one
crowdfunded kids show and the investment
round is filling up fast so if you want
to help bring the tuttle twins show to
life
you can go to tuttletwins.tv that's
www.tuttletwins.tv to learn more about
the investment opportunity today that's
www.tuttletwins.tv
you know you really got to trust your
instincts uh
and so when you hear you know i always
hear these claims from from
from people when they're pushing like
vegan
or soy based substitutes for real food
or now they're pushing bugs and they're
saying uh you know have a bug burger
made of uh
grasshoppers or crickets it tastes just
like the real thing
and i never try that stuff but i always
know i'm just like there's no way it
tastes the same
it just doesn't and so yes this past
weekend i i tested the theory i was at
my in-laws house and my sister-in-law
is uh big into vegan ice cream
i don't think she hasn't gone full vegan
herself but some of this stuff so she
has this vegan ice cream it was like
mint chocolate chip
and it looked pretty real and she was
telling me
like no it tastes just you'll never know
the difference it's delicious
and so i tried some of it it was my
first taste of a vegan substitute
and i said i took one spoonful
and it was horrifying don't listen to
anyone who tries to push a vegan ice
cream
on you it tastes you know what it tasted
like melted
chalk doused in pepto-bismol and splenda
that's what it
it was really unsettling actually that's
the word i was trying to figure out
there's something yeah it's it's
horrible it's bad it's also kind of
creepy it's it's weirdly inorganic
and inedible it tasted
dyspeptic and and and dystopian even
it's like a ration they might serve in a
prison cell on mars
in the year 2075. it was really i didn't
like it in other words
stick with the real stuff um there's my
psa for you let's move on white house
covid coordinator jeffrey zince or zains
i sure try to pronounce it he was on uh
cnn this weekend and he had some news
on when we might begin earning more
privileges
as a country uh because we have to earn
our privileges from the government and
here's what
zanes has to say i think one of the
reasons why
journalists are annoyingly harping on
this and some health experts are
is because there is a light at the end
of the tunnel and
president biden being able to take off
his mask in a room full of
journalists and white house staffers all
of whom are fully vaccinated
is a demonstration that the vaccines
work you and i
are both vaccinated and you and i are in
a room together talking
and i have no fear that i'm going to get
the virus from you and i assume vice
versa
and i think the concern is that by being
overly cautious the signal is going out
to the public
uh that there isn't necessarily a light
at the end of the tunnel do you
understand why people
i think i think everyone is tired um and
wearing a mask is
it can be a pain but we're getting there
and the light at the end of the tunnel
is brighter and brighter
let's keep up our guard let's follow the
cdc guidance
and the cdc guidance across time will
allow vaccinated people more and more
privileges to take off that mask
he really looks looks and sounds exactly
as you expect
all of these all of these
petty tyrants they all have
exactly it's hard to really put your
finger on but they have a certain look
about them
um but he says you can earn privileges
you know kind of like as a parent uh
this is this is what we
you know that's what i do with my kids a
lot of parents
it's you you can your kids can earn
privileges you can take privileges away
if they're if they're misbehaving you
say okay i was gonna let you watch uh
a television show for 30 minutes but you
can't do that anymore we're taking the
privilege away
and that's how we're being treated
it is it is really exactly like we've
we've
talked about the nanny state for years
and years um
in the last year we have fully
experienced what a nanny state really is
because that is how we're being treated
as children
from the very beginning of this thing
that's why the very that's the reason
they gave us
when they originally told everyone don't
wear a mask and dr fauci said
don't wear a mask it's not going to do
much for you
that's what he originally said back in
like march
and then just like that they changed on
a dime and said never mind
actually wear the mask and if you don't
you're going to be murdering uh
your your grandparents
and then when a few and most people just
went along with it and said well okay
don't wear the mask wear it whatever you
tell me but when a few people said hey
hold on a second you were you were just
telling us don't wear one it doesn't
have any effect and now you're and the
reason we gave we were given was uh
well we had to tell you that because
otherwise you would have run out and
hoarded all the masks and there wouldn't
be any left for
medical professionals so treating us
like children
but again plenty of people are perfectly
happy being treated this way
that is that's the most disturbing
reality of all
and those of us who are self-respecting
adults it's hard for us to
comprehend but
there are so many other adults would-be
adults
um supposed adults in this country who
who really
you know they crave that sort of
maternal embrace
from their government and they're
perfectly happy with it
dr fauci has had us in his maternal
embrace for the last year
and he was asked this week and as the
every he
is on the news every day and they're
asking this question of when can we get
back to normal when can we get back to
normal
and he says something different every
day however he happens to be feeling
um but i think this is the first time
that he gave a pretty definitive
end date sort of and here's the end date
that he gave
give everyone a sense of what the
country is going to look like next
mother's day
well george i hope that next mother's
day we're going to see a dramatic
difference than what we're seeing right
now i believe that we will be
about as close to back to normal as we
can and there's
there's some conditions to that george
we've got to make sure that we get the
overwhelming
proportion of the population vaccinated
when that happens
the virus doesn't really have any place
to go there aren't a lot of vulnerable
people
around and where there are not a lot of
vulnerable people around you're not
going to see a surge
you're not going to see the kinds of
numbers we see now
that being the case i think we could
approach what we used to remember
as normal before all of this tragedy
happened
a year from now mother's day of next
year as we get back to normal now
of course i've been living i'm certainly
living entirely my normal life
uh now and i've been living as normal as
i can from the beginning
the extent that i could when everything
was being shut down all around us but uh
and a lot of us
a lot of you it's it's been the same
so it's a very weird thing
it had already felt like we're living in
different countries
ideologically but now that that's that's
uh you know now that's really being
emphasized because
when you when you hear people especially
living on the coasts or living
in blue states still saying when can we
get back to normal when can we
where can we go to the sit down at a
restaurant
what i've been doing that this whole
time
we're at a point now where it really
doesn't matter
i think what the policies are
or certainly what guys like fauci have
to say
um because i think we're getting to the
point where
the people who are still locked down to
whatever extent
or they're under mask mandates or
anything they they want it
and that that's why these places have
gotten away with putting these
policies and keeping these policies in
place for so long is because
as i've been saying for weeks now a lot
of people their brains have been broken
their wills have been broken and they're
perfectly happy with it they don't want
to go back to normal
i was just saying on on twitter someone
i forget who a blue check
saying that he he he went to an indoor
retail establishment
a few days ago for the first time in 14
months
can you imagine that i can't he actually
had not been to a store
in over a year
there was never a time when i stopped
going to stores inside not one
moment during this whole thing
but that's someone like so many others
that he just is
he's not really hankering to get back to
any kind of normal life he's fine with
norm with that with that
being done
we talk about masking and there are so
many people
as startling as it might be to imagine
there are so many people who are fine
wearing a mask forever they don't want
to take it off
and so the balkanization that we've
already seen in this country is only
going to be exacerbated
um more and more now
where i think you know two years from
now three years from now
there could be places in this country
that are still that are still
masking limitations
indoor limits and that kind of thing i
don't know if they'll ever go back
and then there will be other places like
free states where you could basically
live your life which is already where we
are
for the most part all right um the cia
is doubling down on its
woke advertising got a lot of criticism
for the last one
you know the woman bragging about being
a cisgender millennial with
with anxiety disorder and talking about
you know all
the different identity boxes that she
checks and see how he got criticized for
that but they don't care
and here's the latest advertisement that
they just put out a couple days ago
as an agency librarian i work to ensure
that our collection and services are
matched up with what cia needs
not only am i involved in the
acquisitions of journals books
and countless electronic resources i'm
also encouraged to curate special
collections that challenge expectation
recently i brought in our intelligence
gaming collection to give officers
unique opportunities to practice skills
they need in their various roles
instead of sitting for hours in front of
a computer-based training they can play
a carefully selected game
to train a specific set of skills while
simultaneously building on the myriad
soft skills essential to intelligence
work
my favorite thing about cia is that they
encourage the out of the box ideas that
drive real progress
growing up gay in a small southern town
i was lucky to have a wonderful and
accepting family
i always struggled with the idea that i
might not be able to discuss my personal
life at work
imagine my surprise when i was taking my
oath at cia
and i noticed a rainbow on then director
brennan's lanyard which i later learned
was designed by angle
one of the many employee resource groups
here at the agency i remember being
stunned
since then however i've learned that far
beyond the resource groups
inclusion is a core value here officers
from the top down work hard to ensure
that every single person
whatever their gender gender identity
race
disability or sexual orientation can
bring their entire self to work
every day nothing to be worried about
there
just the cia now spending their times
spending their time at work
in a rainbow pin playing preschool games
that's what that's apparently what cia
agents do now at work they sit down uh
to build their critical thinking skills
or whatever they play
video games and little preschool games
rubik's cubes
um that's the cia now and and you know
it's it's very important that
uh we we allow cia agents
on the job to discuss their personal
life to talk about their sexual
proclivities
their gender identity very very
important
and it is it's important to the left
it's not just important it's the whole
point of everything
the left does not recognize that
anything has a purpose or function
beyond
advancing its ideas it's world view
it sees that as the primary function
of everything and everyone and
especially of every institution
so the cia yes the family unit yes
that's the primary function of
everything so this isn't this isn't
going to change
but it does show you um
just how deep the leftist rot
is in our country and in our
institutions
this stuff is embedded deep in there
and leftists have been working towards
this goal give them some credit
they've been working towards this goal
relentlessly and ruthlessly
and and sort of brilliantly
um for decades this is not happening by
accident
it's not like everyone woke up yesterday
and went insane
and next thing you know the cia they're
wearing rainbow pins and playing you
know
playing video games on the job talking
about their gender identity and their
gender expression
that's not it may seem like that to
those of us who haven't been paying
attention
but uh no this this is very intentional
it's a process that's been happening
for many many years and that's why
undoing it and getting rid of the rot
revitalizing our our culture reclaiming
our culture
that is not going to be you know a
one two three step solution or just
flipping a switch or something it's not
going to happen that way and
it's also a problem that goes
way beyond simply electing republicans
to fix
republicans who have shown no interest
in fixing any of this
have really been a part of this problem
at best have done
nothing to stop it and that worse have
have taken part in
this process um
but that's why conservatives need to get
out of this
this way of thinking where it always
comes down to elections and we just got
to get a republican in the white house
and that's all that matters
this it achieves nothing if that's all
if we're for only that's that's
surface level you're only focused at the
very very top
but as i said this rot goes deep way
deeper than that
um kind of related i guess sarah
silverman has
called out caitlyn jenner in no
uncertain terms and i
one of the reasons i play this is you
you may remember
a few weeks ago sarah silverman was
getting credit um from conservative
media
people uh and by a lot of conservatives
because on
this same podcast she spoke out against
the uh ex the extremes of leftism and
was saying that you know
leftism is getting too extreme and
anytime someone on the left says
something like that
conservatives eat that right up and i
was i was expecting
that sarah shovelman she might get a
cpac invitation because she said that
and maybe after what i'm about to play
she'll still get one i don't know
but i remember saying at the time that
yeah what she's saying is
basically true and good the left they
are extreme
but she she's part of that
she is also an extreme leftist
as evidenced by this i saw caitlyn
jenner
saying trans girls should not play girls
sports caitlyn you're a woman
right a trans girl
is a girl she should have the same
rights as
cis girls
if you think a trans girl what you think
a trans girl is too strong
i what about tall girls
as opposed to short girls what about a
boys in high school who are
teeny tiny and their teammates uh have
already hit puberty and are shaving
why don't you just have co-ed sports
divided by weight or
height i you know this is so dumb
they are legislating this without one
single example
of how this plays out
this is not worrying about girl sports
uh believe me not i think
there are better ways to worry about
girl sports
this is not worrying about this is not
what that is this is not worrying
this is not concern for girls sports
it's transphobia full stop
it's just such a bummer when a you know
such a prominent trans woman is such a
you know it's like being jewish right
now and
having the most recognizable jewish
names be weinstein and epstein you know
it's like
super not awesome but super not awesome
very eloquently put so uh yeah that's
all the conservatives that we're
celebrating sarah silverman she's on our
side
she's she's tired of the leftist
extremism
no she thinks that she thinks that women
have penises she thinks that men can
have babies okay
that's as extreme a position as you can
take
and it's as insane of a position as you
could take and
that's what she believes or claims to
anyway
so no no that's not someone who who
holds that view
cannot be on our side at least on any
side that i recognize
there's no like well yeah she she
believes that and is advocating for
a world where that is um where you know
that operates according to that false
reality uh but but
you know she's she can be an ally in
other areas no she can't
and by the way and you hear this all the
time from the left um
on the trans sports issue where they say
you there's no examples this isn't
happening anywhere
give me one example okay i could give
you dozens of examples
it is happening we could start in
connecticut
we're biological males with with with uh
track times
that would not have qualified them for
even like the top 20
were crushing the female competition
in uh in the the state championships
that's one example there are plenty of
examples of this happening
um but with that said i think i think
silverman is sort of right about two
things
um the first thing that she's right
about
what are the two things let me remember
pulling a rick perry okay
the first thing that she's right about
is that this is not just about
girl sports she's right about that and i
i think that's a reality that that
that's a truth that conservatives need
to be honest about and need to embrace
and need to be open about
you trying to stop biological males from
getting onto girl sports teams why are
we motivated to do that well let me
speak for myself anyway
i can that's because i all i can do why
am i motivated to do that
why do i want to prevent this is it
simply because of my
passion for girls sports is
my my ultimate worry is it that uh
we'll live in in a country where there
are no girl sports
no i want there to be girl sports
but is it the most important thing in
the world to me it's not
am i up at night lying awake tossing and
turning say what about girl sports
it's an attack on girl sports no
um i recognize that girl sports
is but one battlefield
in the overall war for reality
and it's an important battlefield
because it's getting a lot of attention
and because of the precedent that will
be set if we lost in this battlefield
so that's i'm not worried about losing
girls sports specifically
i'm worried about losing our grip as a
culture on reality
and when you lose reality girl sports is
like the least of your problems
if we live in a country where where
where
we have abandoned reality itself
and science and all that makes sense
uh yeah we won't have girl sports
anymore we also won't have like anything
else
i fully admit that
so when someone like sarah silverman
accuses us of um
being motivated by more than just a
concern for girl sports i say
absolutely you are damn right
that's what all conservatives should be
saying
but instead most republicans if they
dare even speak on this issue
they pretend that no this isn't about
transgenderism at all this is only about
uh protecting girls sports we care so
much about girl sports
oh please be honest about what you're
doing
i agree with sarah silverman on that be
honest
it's not like we we have some insidious
it's not like our real motivations are
insidious
we're trying to protect reality that's
the point here
kind of important what's the other thing
she's right about joe she's also right
that uh
caitlyn jenner's position is incoherent
she's 100 right because caitlyn jenner
is saying
i'm a woman and we're supposed to accept
him as a woman
and yeah if he's really a woman then
why shouldn't he be able to participate
in female sports
and if a trans girl is really a girl
then why shouldn't they be able to
participate in girl sports doesn't make
any sense
see the the the objection
to trans quote unquote trans girls
participating in girl sports
only makes sense if it's grounded in an
acknowledgment
that trans girls aren't really girls
because if they are girls then obviously
they belong in girl sports
in fact if they are girls and we are
disqualifying them from girl sports that
is discrimination that's
like bigotry right
our point is that they're not girls
i am not aware of any argument against
allowing quote unquote trans girls in
girls sports
aside from the argument that they're not
really girls
that's my whole argument i have no other
argument it's a pretty simple argument i
think it's a good one
why shouldn't they go in girls sports oh
well because they're not girls
i understand that you've given them a
label with the word girl in it
but they're not really girls though
they're not the same
there's a an essential fundamental
difference between them
and the actual girls that's the argument
that's the whole argument so
if but if we're accepting that trans
girls are girls
then there's no argument your argument
makes no sense
that's why you might think that caitlyn
jenner is the perfect
mouthpiece for this because oh look a
trans person's coming out against it
his position doesn't make sense it's
incoherent
caitlyn jenner are we supposed to accept
you as a woman or not
are you telling us now you're not a
woman because if you are saying you're a
woman
then by by that standard
yes these trans people should be in girl
sports
this is what happens on the right and i
don't accept caitlyn jenner's being on
the right by the way but
this is what happens on the right when
we don't have the guts and the
intelligence and the wherewithal
to be honest about what we're doing and
what our argument is
and to make the fundamental argument
rather than
staying on the surface trimming around
the edges you know
get down to the nitty-gritty this is
what the argument is really about
what is the what is the sports argument
really about it's about the question of
whether or not
those quote-unquote trans girls are
actually girls our position is no they
aren't
that's it if you're too afraid to say
that
then you're useless and you're worthless
in this discussion please butt out
because whatever argument you're making
is pathetic and bad
if that's not your argument
all right um let's move now to reading
the youtube comments arthur says the
worst part about that mask video is the
guy who filmed it is the cry baby who
actually thought it was a good idea to
post it online
that should scare us more than the virus
yeah that's always
all of these uh many tick tock videos
are like this and all these mask shaming
videos
uh where the the the undisputed villain
in the encounter is the one filming it
and not just filming it
like it's not like they are live
streaming it and uh
they they lose their temper in the
moment and it goes out
on the internet for all time no they
film it
and then watch it back like they film
their own emotional breakdown
and they film themselves being a bully
to someone in this case this man
berating a pregnant woman
and getting up in her face he films it
watches it back and says this is great
stuff let me post it online for everyone
to see
um maximilian says matt i think you need
to pick another hideous shirt because
everyone likes the polka dot shirt now
well that's why would i pick another one
the plan is working
this is what this is this is
indoctrination you're all getting a
lesson
in indoctrination this is how it works
in desensitization conditioning and
indoctrination
and even hypnotism all of those all
together
let's see wm
music says matt do you think rote
obedience leads to true obedience or a
desire to obey
uh there's caveats and qualifiers but
basically yes i think so
what that's what we were talking about a
second ago that's what we're seeing in
our culture right now
um people at first being forced to obey
mask mandates shutdowns and all of that
and now there are millions of people
who actually have a desire to obey them
they don't want the rules to go away
so yeah absolutely orange banana says
hey matt
sauna is pronounced sauna
s-o-w-n-a
like what sauna sauna
i was just sitting over there now sauna
that's not how it's pronounced it's
sauna
sauna a u ah sauna
like i may not have graduated college or
even gone to college but i know it's not
sauna
can you imagine going to i don't know
like a spa or
i can't imagine going to a spa in the
first place but if you do and you're
walking hey where's your sauna
um and finally jesus freak says i don't
have anything important to say i'm just
commenting so matt might read it well
there you go and thank you for your
service and feeding the algorithm
uh i do appreciate that well if you own
an apple device i've got some good news
for you all of the daily wire
daily wires latest news commentary and
analysis is now finally available on
apple news we cover everything that
you're not getting anywhere else so if
you want to make your news feed
infinitely better
just head to apple news on your device
search for the daily wire and hit the
follow button also
as i'm sure you know the daily wire has
been of course
growing like crazy we've got a lot of
exciting things we've done over the last
six months and we plan to do in the
future we want to make sure that we
include you
in our plans which is why we've been
telling you about these surveys which
will help us
develop uh you know work with sponsors
that that are going to offer services
and goods and services that uh that you
especially
need so please go to dailywire.comwalsh
and fill out my audience survey to tell
us a little bit more about yourself
and to make it a little bit of a sweeter
deal you'll get entered to win a 1 000
gift card but you only get entered for
once for each
show's survey so make sure to listen to
ben shapiro michael knowles and andrew
clavin
and find out how you can access their
survey as well and you can enter to win
those gift cards uh that way also again
my survey link is dailywire.com
walsh we'd love to hear from you there
and now let's get to our daily
cancellation
now for our daily cancellation we turn
to the tragic story of one pop
smoke he was a rapper from brooklyn who
was shot and killed last year apparently
little was known about the murder until
just the past few days when the media
reported that pop smoke's killer was a
15 year old kid
who along with a few friends invaded his
home at 4 30 in the morning to steal his
jewelry in the process of taking his
jewelry
they shot him in the chest and killed
him allegedly a 15 year old admitted to
the crime in jailhouse conversations
that were recorded
unbeknownst to the 15 year old i think
ultimately the rapper died over a rolex
watch which was all they made off with
they sold that for two thousand dollars
so a man died for two thousand dollars
split between four guys
now when news of the killer's identity
broke over the weekend there was a lot
of reaction on social media from people
lamenting and wondering how a 15 year
old kid
could engage in this kind of senseless
violence many rap fans and pop smoke
fans
simply couldn't believe that such a fate
could befall pop smoke
that his life could be lost for such a
frivolous reason
and indeed it is very sad
but it may not be quite as surprising as
they make it out to be
i confess that i was not familiar with
pop smoke's work uh while he was still
living but out of curiosity
i did look up some of his songs after
reading the latest news
and not surprisingly pop smoke appears
to be a rapper in the traditional
variety
with lyrics like this from his song dior
he says i'll make a movie like tnt glock
30 on me
ask who really want it i bet i air it
like bnb
nappy blue wild into my section and i
keep that 38 for that weapon
remember when i came home from
corrections all the bad is in my
direction
and lyrics like this from the song get
it on me or got it on me sorry
this ar be my trophy shoot first shoot
back automatic win the woo clap
then there's a poetry like this from
welcome to the party gun on my hip
one in the head ten in the clip baby
baby don't trip just lower your tone
cause you could get hit
and finally who could forget the song
gangsta which uh with a passage like
this
44 got a kick back click clack get back
shots at your rib pack
or you're gonna get chin checked talk
about their guns but never shot
might as well put a cap on it all over
with a chopstick run up and i'm branding
them 38s on the block won't hesitate
okay plenty more of that came from
pretty standard stuff
yet we're never supposed to stop and
wonder
if this standard may be having perhaps
some kind of effect on the world is it
possible that
when the music industry churns out
thousands and thousands and
thousands of songs every year directly
glorifying and encouraging street
violence
that maybe it could after a while
actually actually succeed in helping to
create
the very behavior that it is so
explicitly promoting
now i'm not suggesting that pop smoke's
killer was directly influenced
by pop smoke himself maybe he was maybe
he wasn't i don't know
all i'm saying is is that the rapper
contributed to a culture that goes out
of its way to romanticize
exactly the sort of thing that pop
smokes killers killer did to him
in other words when someone in an
industry that glorifies street violence
dies by street violence would it perhaps
be time for a bit of reflection
should we consider about you know should
we wonder about all of these dots that
line up so perfectly
just begging to be connected now i
brought this up over the weekend and as
expected
most of the responses were rather
negative some were along the lines of
this comment from a guy named akbar
jenkins who said
i hope matt experiences street violence
yes if you're upset that i said rap
encourages violence the way to prove me
wrong is to wish death on me
good plan and then many other comments
were making points similar to the one
that someone named trevor makes here he
says this is like saying the writers of
the saw franchise had it coming if some
twisted fan decided to ensnare them in a
real-life jigsaw trap
now you often hear these comparisons
between violence and rap and violence in
film
but there are two very significant
differences
first of all the movie saw does not
glorify or romanticize serial killers
you're not supposed to watch that movie
and come away with a sympathetic view of
the killer from saul you're not supposed
to think
that it looks kind of cool to trap
people in a room and force them to
amputate their own limbs in order to
escape
generally anyone imitating the jigsaw
killer from saw would have done it on
halloween and that's about it
with all that said i do think that the
violence in saul was grotesque and
gratuitous and desensitizing
those were garbage movies with no
artistic value whatsoever
but they very clearly were not trying to
send the message of
hey kids being a serial killer is fun
second difference saw was obviously
fiction
it was a story it was a tale most horror
movies are the same
you're not supposed to confuse it with
real life and most people don't
you go into the film fully understanding
that you're entering into a fictional
world where
unreal things are happening
now let's compare all of that to rap
music the rap music like from guys like
pop smoke
does rap music glorify and romanticize
violence
does it try to make murder and drug
dealing seem cool
does it try to make these things seem
appealing
yes no question kids don't go around
dressing
speaking and acting like the serial
killers from horror films
most of the time again unless it's
halloween but kids especially kids in
the city
do absolutely imitate rappers imitate
them in every way from speech to style
to yes behavior
the music is designed to have this
effect everybody involved in making the
music
knows that it's having this effect there
is no escaping that reality they can't
plead ignorance
they're sending a clear message that
especially if you're a boy growing up in
an urban area
the way to prove that you're tough and
cool is to deal drugs and murder people
there is no mistaking that message it is
very direct
second rap music does not present itself
as fiction
now it might be true that some of these
guys are lying about their criminal
exploits but
they certainly don't try to make it seem
like they're lying or telling fables
they again go out of their way to
convince the listener that they really
have done and continue to do
all of the things they describe in their
music oftentimes they'll explicitly
address
and reject the claim that they're lying
or pretending pop smoke and one of those
songs i just read
makes it clear that some people talk
about guns but never shoot anything
and he is not one of those people
he wants you to know that he really has
killed people and he's killed them for
almost no reason he says uh like kill
someone because
he doesn't like their tone and that all
of this makes him very cool and in fact
way cooler than the average
rapper in the game that's the message he
wants you to pick up
a gospel passage about living by the
sword and dying by it comes to mind
so the fact is clear these guys
definitely encourage the chaos and
brutality in our cities
they do it for profit they do it because
the human cost means nothing to them
and sometimes the monster they help to
create turns around on them
yeah it's a sad way to die you know it's
an even sadder way to live
and make a living it's all just very sad
and maybe one of these days when
everyone gets tired of being sad
we can acknowledge the reality that's
staring us plainly in the face and have
a serious conversation
about what exactly we might do to change
it
until then those unwilling to have this
conversation and connect all these dots
are
as you may have guessed by now canceled
and um media matters have fun with that
segment
i'll talk to you guys tomorrow godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky the
show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. today on the
ben shapiro show
the biden economy misses wildly on job
expectations while the white house pays
people to stay home
vaccination demand drops precipitously
thanks to joe biden's messaging failures
and we examine the latest conflagration
in the middle east
media as always are getting it wrong
it's today on the bench bureau shall
give it a listen